it's thursday and time for our pet of
the week segment john with the animal
foundation is here and today
we're talking about tony good morning
john
tell us all about tony you said he's
just kind of a lovable
goofball he is he's four years old he's
86 pounds he's pulling out a couple
pounds since he's been with us
but he's just a lovable big goofball and
you know you've heard that adage
man's best friend i'll tell you what if
you're looking for a friend
tony's your guy oh and you say he just
loves attention tell us about that yeah
he loves attention he'll actually reach
out and grab you as you can see from
some of the videos
he'll reach out and grab and say hey
why'd you stop petting me get me some
more
what would you say to anybody who might
be interested in tony
you don't have appointments anymore
we're on a walk-in traffic
walk-in basis we open at 11 every day so
we encourage people to come on down
sometimes people are waiting at 11. uh
so there might be a little bit of a lie
but
if you're interested in tony come on
down his adoption fee is 50
so he's a great great dog thank you john
as always for your time and we look
forward to tony getting a great home
what a sweet face well if you'd like to
adopt tony just give the animal
foundation a call later today or you can
go down
there the number seven zero two nine
five five five nine zero one he's fifty
dollars to adopt
and we've got this information on our
website eightnewsnow.com
you don't have to make an appointment
anymore bianca you can just go to the
animal foundation
but john says the line yeah there's
usually a line at 11 a.m when they open
there is i can speak truth to that i've
seen it for myself we went there a
couple of weeks ago to do the
remember that we did the kitten oh
nursery the line
was long oh boy okay there's people with
their umbrellas ready to stand in the
sun to get their
pet to take home forever home